Welcome to level
three exponents.
Let's get started.
So if I asked you what 4 to the
1/2 power is, your immediate
inclination is to view this
probably as like a
multiplication problem and try
to multiply it somehow or add
them or something.
And you always have to
remind yourself this
is not multiplication.
I know when I first learned it,
I always was tempted to do
something with multiplication.
Well, something to the 1/2
power might not be intuitive to
you, but it actually turns out
that this means the same thing
as the square root of 4.
Or another way, what times
itself is equal to 4,
and we know that the
square root of 4 is 2.
It could actually be a positive
2 or a negative 2 because we
know that either of those
numbers when they're
squared could equal 4.
But for the sake of this one
we'll assume it's always
the positive square root.
So 4 to the 1/2 is equal to 2.
Similarly, 9 to the 1/2,
well that would be 3.
16 to the 1/2 -- oops.
16 to the 1/2, my subconscious
gave away the answer.
16 to the 1/2 power is 4.
25 to the 1/2 power is 5.
I think that might make
sense to you now.
So what does it mean when
something is to the 1/3 power?
Well, if I say 8 to the
1/3 power, you might
already catch on.
In the 1/2 power we said
something times something
is equal to 4.
Well in the 1/3 power we have
to say that something to the
third power is equal to 8.
And if you've been practicing
your exponents you know that 2
to the third power
is equal to 8.
So we know that 8 to
the 1/3 is equal to 2.
Similarly, 27 to the
1/3 is equal to 3.
And 64 to the 1/3
is equal to 4.
You might notice that I'm
picking particular numbers,
like 8 and 27, 64.
That's because they have
clean, cube roots.
And then by the way, when
something is to the 1/3 power
that's the same thing as
saying the cube root.
I just used terminology
without explaining it,
which is very bad.
So I just used 8 and 27 and 64
because when I raised them to
the fractional exponents, they
actually come out to
be clean numbers.
You could use a calculator and
do something like 5 to the 1/3
power and you'll get
some weird decimal.
Let's do some more problems.
So we know that 9 to
the 1/2 is equal to 3.
Well what do you think 9
to the 2/3 is equal to?
Well, it turns out that this is
equivalent to 9 to the -- oops,
I actually didn't want to do
those -- what do you think 9
to the 3/2 is equivalent to?
Well this is the same thing
as 9 to the 1/2 power
to the third power.
And I'll do a whole
presentation on the actual
principles of exponents, but
it actually turns out you
could just multiply.
When you have one exponent
to another is when you can
multiply the two and that's
where you get 3/2 .
But 9 to the 1/2 we know is 3.
And you're raising it to the
third power, so that equals 27.
I'm sure at this point
I have confused you.
Let's do more of these.
So you know at this point
that 16 to the 1/4 power --
think about what that is.
That means that some number
to the fourth power is 16.
If you've been practicing your
level one exponents, you'll
probably know that well, that
equals 2, because 2 times 2
times 2 times 2, well
that equals 16.
So we know that 16 to
the 1/4 is equal to 2.
So what do you think 16
to the 2/4 is equal to?
Well, we already know from that
last problem that that's the
same thing as 16 to the 1/4
squared -- that's the 2 on both
sides -- and we know 16 to the
1/4 is 2, so that equals 2
squared and that equals 4.
And it all works out because we
know from fractions another way
to write the fraction
2/4 is to write 1/2.
So this is the same thing
as 16 to the 1/2 power.
16 to the 1/2 power, well
that's just equal to 4.
Now I'm going to mix it up real
good and do some negative
fractional exponents.
So what if I were to tell you
16 to the negative 1/2 power?
Well this might seem very
daunting at first, but as we
know with the negative
exponents level three,
immediately we just say well
this is the same thing as 1
over 16 to the positive 1/2.
And that's the same thing as 1
to the 1/2 over 16 to the 1/2.
Well the square root
of 1 is easy, it's 1.
And 16 to the 1/2 is 4.
So that wasn't too bad.
It's a little daunting when you
see a negative exponent, but
immediately when you see that
negative, just flip the 16 and
then work it out like a regular
fractional exponent problem.
Let's do another one.
8 over 27 to the negative 1/3.
Immediately when we
see that negative, we
want to just flip it.
So we'll say that equals 27
over 8 to the 1/3, and that
equals 27 to the 1/3
over 8 to the 1/3.
And we know that 27 to the
1/3, well that equals 3.
And 8 to the 1/3,
well that equals 2.
So we've got 8 over 27 to
the negative 1/3 is 3/2.
The first problem probably
looked very intimidating to
you, but it only took us two
steps to get there and as you
do more practice, hopefully
it'll seem more and
more intuitive to you.
Let me give you
another problem.
What's negative 8 to the
negative third power?
Let me change that.
What's negative 8 to the
negative 1/3 power?
Once again, at first this might
confuse you, but when you see
that negative in the exponent,
we just take the reciprocal of
the base, so that we say that
that is equal to negative 1
over 8 to the 1/3 power.
And we say well that is equal
to, we could write it as 1
over negative 8 to the 1/3.
We say what number times itself
3 times is equal to negative 8?
Well, we know from intuition
there's no real mechanical way
to do this, but we know that
negative 2 times negative 2 is
4 times negative
2 is negative 8.
So we know that this is
equal to 1 over negative
2 or negative 1/2.
So negative eight to
the negative 1/3 is
equal to minus 1/2.
Let's do another one, one more
problem just to thoroughly
melt your brain.
Let's say 9 over 4 to
the negative 3 over 2.
Well, immediately we see
that negative exponent,
let's flip the base.
We get 4 over 9 to the 3/2 .
Well we know that that equals
4 over 9 to the 1/2, and all
of that to the third power.
4 over 9 to the 1/2, I think at
this point you know that's the
same thing as 4 to the 1/2
which is 2 over 9 to
the 1/2 which is 3.
Now we have to just raise
everything to the third power.
And that's the same thing as
2 the third power which is
8 divided by 3 to
the third power.
Well that's 27.
There we have 9/4 to the
negative 3/2 power is
equal to 8 over 27.
Now hopefully you can at
least do these problems.
You probably don't have a good
intuitive sense for exactly
what a negative 3/2 power is,
and hopefully I can cover that
for you in future modules.
But I think you're ready to
try some of the level three
exponent practice problems.
Have fun.